let me ask you a completely ridiculous
question
uh but it's a fascinating one for me
from an engineering and a scientific
perspective
when i look at a sport really any
problem
one way to ask how difficult is this
is to see how can i build a machine
that competes with a human being at that
problem you can look at chess
you can look at soccer robocup
and then you could look at grappling
there's something about when you start
to think
how would i build an ai system a robot
that defeats
somebody like a gordon ryan where it
forces you to really
think about formalizing this art
as a as an engineering discipline in the
same way you do but you
you you still have some art injected in
there there's no space for art when you
actually have to build the system that's
not a ridiculous question that's a
damned interesting question
let's put aside like like i mentioned
with the boston dynamics spot robots
what people don't realize is the amount
of power
they can deliver is huge so let's take
that weapon aside
just the amount of force you're able to
deliver yeah yeah
i'm glad you're specifying that um
so essentially your question is okay can
can a talented group of engineers create
a robot which could defeat gordon ryan
on the face of it um as you just pointed
out that's the easiest project in the
world
just create a robot that carries a nine
millimeter automatic and shoot them five
times in the chest okay that's that
gordon ryan's done
um so that's not the interesting
question the interesting question
and i if i understand you correctly is
if we
had the ability to create a robot
whose physical powers were identical to
gordon ryan
not inferior and not superior
what would it take to create a mind
inside that robot that would be gordon
ryan in the majority of matches yeah and
there's two ways to build
ai systems this is true for autonomous
driving for example
which has been quite contested recently
so one is you
basically one way to describe is you
have a giant set of rules
it's like this tree of rules where you
apply a different condition when there's
a pattern you see
you apply a rule and they're hard coded
in you basically get
like a john donnar type of character who
tries to
encode hard code
into the system all the moves you should
do in every single
case of course you can't actually do
that fully
so you're going to be taking shortcuts
what are called heuristics
just a basic basic kind of
generalizations
and apply your own expertise as an
expert of
in this case grappling to see how that
can be encoded as a rule now the other
approach
elon musk and tesla are taking this
approach which is called machine
learning
which is
create a basic framework of the kind of
things you should be observing
and what are the measures metrics of
success
and then just observe and see which
things lead to success
more success and which lead to less
success and there's a delta
you like when you when you see a thing
first of all the way machine learning
works is you predict
you see a position or you see a
situation
and then you predict how good that is
and then you watch how it actually turns
out
and if it's uh worse or better you
adjust your expectations yes that's
through that
process you can learn quite a lot
the the challenges
and this might be a very true challenge
in grappling
is uh in like in driving
you can't crash so
there's a physical world in chess for
example where this
approach has been exceptionally
successful you can work in simulation so
you can have
a ai system that for example
with as in the case with alpha zero by
deepmind google's demand
it can play itself in simulation
millions of times billions of times
it's difficult to know if it's possible
to do that in stimulation for
for for anything that involves human
movement
like uh grappling so that's
my sense is if we first look at the hard
encoding if you were to try to describe
gordon ryan to a machine how many rules
are in there do you think
yeah um first off let me tell you that's
one of the most fascinating questions
i've ever been asked
and uh i'm tremendously happy to answer
this
um how about what we do is this is a
this is a massive question you've asked
there's a
huge amount of ways this could get very
interesting and very confusing
let's set some ground rules for the
discussion
um lex alluded to
the idea of man versus machine and
chess okay and i think that's a really
good place for us to start
the the discussion um i'm gonna
uh just tell people about a little bit
the history of
man versus chess to give you guys some
uh
some background on this in 1968 there
was a
a party in which a highly ranked not not
a world champion but a highly ranked
chess player and his name was levi
and he met a uh
a computer engineer uh at a party
and they had a a uh
a light-hearted bet that in a 10-year
time frame
a human chess player would be defeated
by a computer now you gotta remember
1968 computing power was very very low
the computers that got america to the
moon were
were actually pretty damn primitive your
iphone would kick all of their asses
um so computational power was very very
low in those days
so interestingly the chess player fully
believed that no computer could beat him
in the 10-year time frame
and the uh the computer engineer was
very optimistic that he was wrong and
in fact 10 years the computer would win
10 years later they had a competition
and the human won
decisively in fact so computational
power
simply hadn't risen to that level yet
through the 1980s computational power
increased
but not sufficient to uh to to get to
championship level
uh there were computer programs in the
1980s which were competitive with
good solid chess players but not world
beaters
understand right from the start that
there's a fundamental problem here
the number of options
that the two players in a chess board
can run through
is astronomically high there are 64
squares on a chess board
the number of possible options that can
could work or could play out on a
chessboard
and this is a truly shocking thing for
you to think about
the number of possible options is higher
than the number of atoms in the
known universe think about that for a
second in terms of
complexity okay the number of atoms on
this
table is massive
okay that is an unbelievably large
number
then we're talking about a situation
where if a computer had to go through
all the options at the onset of a match
they would have to
run numbers greater than the number of
atoms in the known universe the number
of galaxies and the number of
in our universe is vast okay it's
measured in the billions like
the number of atoms that's just a number
so mind-blowing is impossible okay
so no computer
is ever going to be able to work with
those kinds of numbers okay you
that i don't even know if future
generations of quantum computers could
could work it with those kind of numbers
so that's the fundamental problem okay
that the number of options in a
in a chess match is just so
astronomically large
that no computer could ever figure out
all the the available options and make
decisions in a given time frame so
that's
the fundamental problem so as lex
correctly pointed out the way you get
around this
is by the use of heuristics these are
rules of thumb
which give general guidelines to action
so for example in jiu-jitsu i could give
you a general rule of thumb
uh don't turn your back on your opponent
okay that's a solid piece of advice
there are obviously some exceptions to
that rule
but it's a good solid piece of advice to
give a beginner the moment you give that
heuristic rule
you rule out a lot of options okay
you've already told someone don't turn
your back don't turn your back on
someone
so a lot of possibilities have just been
turned away right there
so you've cut the number of options in
half right there just by giving one
heuristic rule
okay if you
were decent at j it's not great but
decent and you knew enough to give say
10 heuristic rules you could chop
that initially vast number of options
down
by a vast amount and now you're starting
to get to a point where if the computer
had sufficient
computational power it could start
getting through
the number of options in that acceptable
time frame so that's
the general pattern of the development
now things started getting very
interesting in the mid 1990s
with ibm's computer deep blue
uh there was a great chess champion of
the late 1980s and early 19
through the 1990s called gary kasparov
who
had been more or less undefeated for a
decade
in 1996 he took on ibm's computer deep
blue
just to correct the record he was
undefeated
i apologize russian got it gotta make
sure they get very nationalistic about
their chairs be careful of these guys
deep blue lost the first confrontation i
believe in 1996 it was competitive but
it lost
then in 1997 uh deep blue
one and it wasn't a complete walkover
kasparov i believe won one of the
matches but uh
they did unequiv deeply unequivocally
won the confrontation
and it was seen as like this watershed
moment where
a computer beat the best human chess
player on the planet
and that was it there was there's no
coming back from that
i think it would be remembered as one of
the biggest moments in computing history
is really when the first time a machine
beat a human and a thing that humans
really care about
in the in the domain of intellectual
pursuits yeah it was it was a
it was a powerful powerful moment now
not only was that a powerful moment but
things started getting truly interesting
from that moment forward
because then you started having
different areas of development
the general way in which the
progress is made from those early starts
in 1968
all the way through to deep blues
victory was of the use of heuristic
rules
that brought down the number of
potential options
to a manageable level as computer power
increased
then it could make faster and faster and
wiser and wiser decisions
and make them at a rate which no human
even the best human could keep up with
so that was the general way in which the
the
debate went um
but things got more interesting after
this with the advent
of computers that as you pointed out
make use of
so-called machine learning
there were a company put out
a program alpha zero which
can look at the basic rule structures
of chess and then ultimately play itself
in trial games and make trial and error
assessment of what are good and bad
strategies
so that with no human intervention
a computer could start doing remarkable
things
not only did uh
this company create alpha zero and there
were some other ones too that they
fought not only in chess but in the much
more complex asian game of go
which has far more potential options
than chester by a very significant
margin yes
these machine learning programs not only
easily defeat any human in chess but in
go
as well and what's truly remarkable is
they weren't just beating them
when alpha zero took on a rival chess
program which by itself was already
superior to any human
it only required four
hours starting from learning the rules
of chess
to figuring out how to beat the second
most powerful chess program in the world
that's insane that's literally like
taking a human
telling the rules of chess they play
some games with themselves
for four hours and they go out and beat
gary kasparov
this is like to me this is a
a truly exciting development far beyond
even what deep blue did
i like he said exciting not terrifying
yeah because i agree with you on the
exciting year
now things also get exciting in a
different direction
there is another possibility which few
people
foresaw after the deep blue episode
this is where a new form of chess
started to emerge
sometimes called cyborg chess or centaur
chess
we're humans of moderate chess level
playing ability
not world champions just decent but not
great
uh i guess you might say like purple
belts and judits allied themselves
with computers so the humans and
computers
worked as a cyborg team
the humans supplied the heuristic
insight
the computers supplied the computational
power
and fascinatingly they proved to be
superior to both the best humans
and the best chess programs
the united force of human insight
with heuristics with computers ability
to go through
uh numbers in far more rapid form than
any human could ever hope to do
proved to be one of the strongest
combinations and enabled
that pairing of human and computer
to overwhelm both the best single human
and the best single computer that adds a
whole new level of fascination to this
topic
so to wind things up here we've got this
fascinating initial question from lex
the idea of
could there be a computer
inside a robot which doesn't have any
special physical properties this is mind
versus mind
because the bodies negate each other the
robot is the same body
as gordon ryan this is a thought
experiment what would it take
to create a mind that would defeat the
mind
of gordon ryan
based on the chess example it would
appear that this is entirely feasible
at some point in the future and in fact
i would go further and say it's actually
quite likely
based on what we've seen from the
example of chess
the rate of progress in a.i in the last
20 years
is or has dwarfed anything from the
previous
50 years and the rate continues
to increase we're talking now to level
with
machine learning defeating world
champions
in chess and go in four hours like
just from starting from the rules of the
sport
um this is this is going to be difficult
for humans to keep up with now
in humans favor could we take gordon
ryan
and put a chip inside his brain that
created the same
cyborg effect as we saw in centaur chess
and cyborg chairs
and then take gordon ryan to a new level
where suddenly his computational powers
were massively increased he still has
his heuristic insight
but he has vastly augmented
computational powers
that's the interesting battle i uh
you asked a great question lex let me
give you my initial
push or for an answer would be that if
it's just gordon ryan
versus your your uh your robot
technology
in 10 years i would say with machine
learning i
say you guys win every time but if it is
cyborg jordan ryan where he's part
part gordon ryan with heuristics and
part machine then
that's and now that's where i throw the
question back at you young man
what do you think well i was fascinated
to hear your answer that's very
interesting because because there's a
there's a lot of different ways you can
build a cyborg gordon ryan so one is
there's the neural link
way which is basically
say doing what you're suggesting which
is
expanding the computational capabilities
of gordon ryan's brain
like directly being able to communicate
between a computer and the brain
so most of you preserve
uh most of what there is in the human
body including the nervous system and
the
the computing system we currently have
that's biological and expanding it with
the computer
there's also on the cyborg chest front
the like magnus carlsen the current
world champion in chess
he studies alpha zero games
like that it's not a regular thing for
high level high-level grandmasters
from what i understand almost every uh
chess master now
studies computer games for for
inspiration like that
just as um uh great chess players from
the past used to go back into old
leather-bound books of previous
grand masters and study games and books
nowadays most people
when they want to study the most perfect
games they actually study
programs like alpha zero yeah and it's
not just for inspiration it's education
it's i mean
it's literally part of their training
right yeah this isn't like a fun
side thing it's just the main way to get
better
so um so there's a certain element there
where
even our human brains could be trained
by observing
the partial explorations
of an ai systems in the space of
grappling
that could be actually in stimulation it
doesn't have to be in the physical world
it could be
uh in if we construct sufficiently good
biomechanical models of human beings
machines can learn
how they grapple there's there's quite a
bit of uh
that already open ai has the system of
uh
there's like sumo wrestlers with some
basic goals of pushing each other off of
a
platform and you know nothing from the
you don't even know
so you have a basic model of a bipedal
system
it doesn't even know in the beginning
how to stand up it just falls
right so it has to learn how to get up
and they do that through self-play
they they learn how to get up they learn
how to move enough to
achieve the final goal which is to push
your opponent off of the thing
fascinating so they've learned
that now open ai is not
those folks are currently not that
interested in the grappling world so
they kind of stop
there yeah but it's very possible in
simulation to then
develop ideas in fact this is something
i should probably do because it's pretty
natural to do and easy
is ideas of control and submission and
all all the
you know you add the ability to
i don't know how to put it nicely but to
uh to
choke your opponent uh and uh to
break their body parts off which is what
is add that in and what kind of
ideas they'll come up with is very
fascinating i
actually don't know until this
conversation i don't know why i never
even thought about that i've been very
obsessed with just like walking and
and running and all those kinds of
things like evolving
different strategies for when you have a
bunch of
so one difficult thing for robots is
when you have uneven terrain
and there's uncertainty about the
terrain it's how to keep walking
or when when there's a bunch of things
being thrown at you all that kind of
stuff and you
learn uh through self-play how to be
able to navigate those on certain
environments when there's a lot of weird
objects and all those kinds of things
there's no reason why you can't just do
that with uh with submissions and so on
in simulation that'll be actually
fascinating
but once we might be surprised by the
kind of strategies
in simulation these ai systems will
develop
and that might make a much better gordon
ryan a much better john donna
in wait in asking the dean lister
question of like why are we only using
why are we not doing x but on the
actual sort of grappling event
in the physical space i've been very
surprised and a little bit disappointed
by how difficult
it's to build
a system that's able to
have the body of gordon ryan or a human
being actually
which means it's not just the the
biomechanics which is very difficult to
do
but also all of the senses that are
involved
be able to perceive the world as richly
to be able to
there's something called soft robotics
which is it's incredibly difficult to do
through touch understand the hardness of
things
we don't understand as human beings just
how
much we're able to touch to experience
the world
and to manipulate the world like the the
the process of picking up a cup
is very similar to the process of
grappling all the feeling
that you do all the leverage that you're
applying there's
so many degrees of freedom in both the
in the interactive sense
in the sensing and the applying sensing
and applying you're doing that
through so much of your body that's just
going to be
very difficult to build a system that's
able to experience the world and act
onto the world
as richly as we humans can yeah if um
if picking up a cup is a seemingly
insurmountable challenge then
then taking someone down controlling
them getting past their legs that's
going to be one hell of a project
exactly i mean there could be shortcuts
but i mean currently that's
um that's that's the field called uh
robotic manipulation which is picking up
objects
usually they have like a ball and a
triangular object and your whole task is
to like pick it up and
move it around generalizing that to the
human
body is harder but
perhaps not so so not as hard as we
might think
the question is how do you construct
experiments where you can do that safely
in chess it's very easy but here
it's very very problematic um
i guess you could just have robot versus
robot
teamed up with each other and then they
learn and then they go out to take on a
human opponent
yes exactly so you have two physical
robots
that interact with each other everything
you've said so far suggests that
many of the problems these tactical
elements they're
easy tasks for humans so which becomes
more powerful more quickly
robots that are taught to think like
humans or humans that are given
the computational power of uh of
of computers and robots themselves which
wins first
a cyborg gordon ryan or an artificial
robot gordon ryan really really strong
question
and i think i think by far the cyborg
gordon ryan yeah that's what i'm
thinking here
the problems you're talking about uh
with regards to the robots those are
those are deep problems like if
if picking up a cup is problematic it's
gonna be
damn difficult to but to a human let's
say you know that two-year-old can do
that
you're highlighting a very important
differences
human beings have something called
common sense
that we don't know how to build into
computers currently that's what picking
up the cup is
is some basic rules about the way this
world works we're able to this is when
we're children and we'll crawl around we
pick up
what humans don't have that machines
have is
incredible computational power and
access to infinite knowledge
computers can do that so if if you have
a gordon ryan with the infinite
knowledge and compute power
that's just going to uh because we know
how to do that
that that's going to uh blow out of the
water
uh update on the um
the phenomenon of cyborg or centaur
chess
there was some debate as to whether or
not um
cyborg chess teams could stay
competitive with the
uh the latest machine learning has there
been any update on that
yeah i believe at this point machines
dominate over the machine human pairs
with the human pairs when they first
came out they were good chess players
but not great chess players does it make
any difference if you have
say gary kasparov and uh
and a computer work in unison versus
yeah
joe blow from no no it does make a huge
difference but yeah both
are destroyed by machines that's
interesting and it's not even
competitive no
no it's not competitive but they also
lost interest in this kind of uh
idea so i think there's still
competitions between
human machine pairs versus human machine
pairs almost like
uh to see how the two work together but
in terms of machine versus human machine
pair
machines still dominate interesting so
and now we've retrieved back as human
beings
caring mostly about human versus human
competition which is
probably what the future will look like
it's very interesting to think
but like that that in chess happen
really quickly
it won't happen and it wasn't so painful
in chess because we care about chess but
it's not so fundamental to human society
in uh when you started talking about
cyborg gordon rhines which really beyond
grappling is referring to
robots operating physical space or human
robot hybrids operating physical space
you're talking about
our society is now full of cyborgs yes
and that that might that transition
might be very painful
or transformative
in a way we can't even predict and that
very much has applications as both
china and us now have legalized
is autonomous weapon systems so
use of these kinds of systems and
military applications
so it used to be there been a big call
in the ai community to ban
autonomous weapons so the use of
artificial intelligence in
in war just like bio weapons are
banned uh internationally so you're not
allowed to use bioweapons in war
and actually most people even terrorists
have kind of agreed on this ban
it's not like a there's been a quiet
agreement like we're not going to be
doing this because
everybody's going to get really pissed
off with autonomous weapons systems
that's not been the case what china
has said that they're going to be using
ai in their military
and uh the us in 2021
just released a report saying that
they're going to um
they're they're going to add increasing
amounts of artificial intelligence
into our military systems into drones
into
just everything that's doing any kind of
both strategic
and actual like bombing and
defense systems i presume uh
a drone army would easily defeat a human
army in the in the near future
like um i mean think about
just off the top of my head just think
about the implication of kamikaze drones
versus a naval fleet i mean kamikazes
was humans in world war
ii did terrible damage to our navy
imagine
swarms of of uh mechanical kamikazes
which have no fear
no remorse i mean but it's very
uh inefficient kamikaze is very
inefficient you want to be very
like war is it's the same discussion to
jiu jitsu right you want to be uh
you want to create an asymmetry of power
and you want to be efficient is in the
way you deliver that power
it actually goes back to the picking up
a cup
currently a lot of things we do in war
like so most of the drones that you hear
about they're not autonomous not most
all they're usually piloted by they're
piloted remotely
by humans and humans are really good at
this kind of
um what's necessary to deliver the most
damage targeted damage
effective as part of the largest
strategy have above bombing the area or
all that kind of stuff
i don't know how difficult that is to
automate i think
the biggest concern i actually have a
sense that's very difficult to
automate the biggest concern is almost
like
an incompetent application of this
and uh consequences that are not
anticipated
so you have a drone army where you say
we want to target you give it power to
target a particular terrorist
and then there's some bug in the system
that
has like for example has a large
uncertainty about the location of that
terrorist
and so decides to bomb an entire city
you know almost like as a bug a software
bug
i'm much more concerned about like bad
programming
and software engineering than i am about
like malevolent ai systems that
destroy the world so the more we rely on
automation
this is the lesson of human history the
more we give to ai
to software to robotic systems
the more we forget how to
supervise and oversee some of the edge
cases
all the weird ways that things go wrong
and then
the more stupid software bugs can lead
to huge damage like
you know even like nuclear explosions
those kinds of things
if we add ai into the launch systems
for nuclear weapons for example
i think human history teaches us that
software bugs
is what will leave lead to world war
iii not malevolent ai or human beings
interesting by the way i deeply
appreciate how knowledgeable you are
about the history of artificial
intelligence that was awesome oh no
it's fascinating stuff you know i
remember reading when i was a child
about
you know during tests and things like
this and visionaries from the 1950s had
ideas but
to see it come this far is just
fascinating to me um
okay so so what can we as jujitsu
players take away from this
we saw that when it comes to computers
versus
humans in chess tournaments humans had
something truly valuable to give to the
computers
that was heuristic rules in every
coaching program
that i run i make an endless
quest to search out and find
effective heuristic rules that's the
basis of a good training program
heuristic rules and principles
give vast informational content
which can rapidly increase your
performance on the mat
just as they rapidly increase the
performance of chess computers
to overcome their human adversaries
the great human weakness is
computational power
most people vastly overestimate their
ability
to reason and problem solve under stress
in fact numerous psychological studies
have shown that humans can balance
a relatively small number of uh
of competing options in in in stressful
decision making
but what we do have what is it the great
and unique
human gift is this idea to come up
and arrive at heuristic rules and
principles which turn out to be
very effective guides to behavior for
both human behavior
and artificially intelligent behavior
make that your focus in study
don't try to remember 10 000 different
details on a move
okay that's that's human weakness not
human strength
our strength is heuristics make that
your focus
not endless computations over 25 details
here merge with 27 details here
that's not a that's not what humans are
good at
the uniquely human strength is arriving
at these heuristic rules and principles
which guide our behavior
which provides simplifications which
enable us to take
vast amounts of information and parry it
down to a few simple rules that
effectively guide our behavior
take that core insight from the
discussion that lex and i just had it
was a complex discussion we both
apologize for going a little bit
overboard
that was awesome then dragging you into
some details there but take that away
from it love it it'll make you better at
jiu-jitsu
sorry legs that was uh
that was a really exciting discussion
and uh
the depths of knowledge in the
dimensions of knowledge you have
and interests you have is just
fascinating
you